i'm really really excited because
i've been trying to do this forever and
even way before covet but i didn't have
a place you know i've seen all the
venues i've seen all the
the residencies from all the other rock
bands i wouldn't see them
the strat just gave me a
welcome open arms whatever you want to
do so i'm really happy
and that room is awesome perfect size
well i've got three bands i've got
chicken foot my favorite band my new
band the circle who's really my band now
and
my old band the wabos who were my
greatest party band in the world we
threw that big party we had people on
stage and had
waitresses bringing us margaritas you
know and and so i'm gonna kind of bring
all everybody in and all my friends that
come to cabo you know toby keith and
kenny chessy country guys and they come
up and and we just play and so the idea
of sammy and friends is whoever shows up
then we just do that and we're going to
change the set list every night
this is an event this is a residency
you're coming to my house i'm going to
create an environment we're going to
have my booze
we're going to have my kind of food so
it's a deeper experience
the excitement about it reopening that's
we came in first as soon as we heard it
was going to be reopening
made the deal to do it and when we can
do it you know the room's booked up
for a lot of other stuff so i'm taking
in my little holes now but next year
my dream would be to do a month on and a
month off
at your service my cabo wabo
uh cantina in mexico where i throw my
birthday party for
30 some years and all these people
i get intimidated by looking people in
the eye while i'm
trying to keep my brain straight
wow well i must admit i'm pleasantly
surprised at
uh june 28th
sammy have our day
very cool
so cool
you